If you want to hear the unknown truth about
where Gordon went in all that time between
Saw and Saw 7
(yeah, I prefer to call it Saw
7 instead of Saw 3D, so get used to it)
then stick around to the end of this video.
Jigsaw, the man who brought his judgement
down upon the world of the Saw franchise had
many disciples who lent him a helping hand
at some point along his journey, but the man
considered to be his greatest asset was
Dr. Lawrence Gordon.
Welcome to Horror History.
My name is the emo version of Kevin from Home
Alone…
I actually used to get that a lot when I was
a kid… minus the emo part…
Today we’re covering a fan favorite.
It’s Dr. Lawrence Gordon.
Gordon was played by actor Cary Elwes, who
appears in the original Saw, and comes back
for Saw 7.
After a financial contract dispute hobbled
the original plans for Gordon to appear in
Saw III, pun intended, Elwes had to wait for
a higher budget before making his return.
But Elwes, much like his character, continued
to keep tabs on the Saw world without making
an appearance for years before his triumphant
comeback.
We’re gonna analyse Dr. Gordon’s entire
life, so let’s take it back to the start
of his story.
Lawrence Gordon graduated from Indiana University’s
School of Medicine on June 4th, 1979.
This was the first major accomplishment he
would achieve in his impressive medical career.
He would become a doctor, surgeon, and later
oncologist at the Angel of Mercy Hospital.
He married a woman named Alison, and in 1996
they gave birth to their only daughter, Diana.
Lawrence and Alison did discuss having another
child after Diana, but ultimately decided
their schedules were too busy, and they barely
had time to concentrate on the daughter they
had.
The busy schedules put a strain on their relationship,
and Dr. Gordon became cold and emotionless
towards his wife as she became pissy and unruly
towards him.
His constant preoccupation with work also
caused his daughter to feel ire towards his
pager and she felt that work got in between
her and her father.
In 2004, Dr. Gordon’s relationship with
his wife was very weak and he’s having an
affair with a medical student at the hospital
named Carla Song.
They would arrange times to meet at seedy
hotel rooms in the middle of the middle of
the night.
In June of 2003, Dr. Lynn Denlon was working
under Dr. Gordon in the oncology department
where they diagnosed a colon cancer patient
named John Kramer with an Inoperable Frontal
Lobe Tumor or Glioblastoma Mulitforme.
Nine months after that, on March 24th, 2004
he was found to have speech altering brain
damage due to more cancerous growths.
When Dr. Gordon called John into his office
to tell him how long he had to live, John
found his demeanor to be cold and harsh.
John felt that he did not cherish life, and
did not appreciate the effects that telling
a man his expiration date would have psychologically.
John planned to rehabilitate the doctor using
an elaborate game that Lawrence would be forced
to partake in.
John would soon become known as “The Jigsaw
Killer” for the trademark Jigsaw piece he
cut out of each of his victims.
In May of 2004 Gordon would learn of Jigsaw
for the first time.
He was out late one night seeing Carla, and
the next day while examining John’s tumor
for an audience of Carla and the other students,
he’s called out for his emotionless medical
proceedings by an orderly named Zep.
Lawrence mocks Zep for having “special bonds
with the patients.”
Before he can get back to his demonstration,
he’s called into his office for another
distraction.
There, he meets two cops, Sing and Tapp, who
question him about his whereabouts the night before.
Gordon’s pen light was found at the crime
scene of one of Jigsaw’s victims where a
man had been burned to death, so the cops
wanted him to provide an alibi.
Not wanting to admit he had cheated on his
wife, Gordon is hesitant to provide his whereabouts
and they take him down to the station.
His lawyer and friend, Brett, recommends that
Gordon give his alibi while he still has a
chance, and in doing so, they’re able to
clear his name, but one of the detectives,
David Tapp, is still suspicious.
They ask Gordon to stay a bit longer to hear
the testimony of one Jigsaw victim that escaped
her trap, so he sticks around to hear the
story of Amanda Young and is horrified by
the brutality, but still has no answers as
to why his pen light was found.
Merely knowing about Jigsaw was not enough
to get Gordon to change his ways though, because
five months later, in October, he’s up late
working once again when his daughter Diana
has a little sleepwalking incident and asks
to see her Dad.
He doesn’t even look up from his computer
as his wife tells him about what happened.
I imagine this is what I look like when I’m
editing a video.
He does eventually go to put her to bed and
check the room with her because she believes
there’s a man in there.
“There’s no such thing as the bad man.
Now can you go to sleep?”
I would beg to differ, but it’s Lawrence
doesn’t notice anyone in the room, and eventually
gets called away when Carla tries to contact
him using his pager.
On his way out, his wife tries to pick a fight
with him, because she’s completely starved
for passion in the relationship.
He meets Carla at a run down joint known as
The Hotel Barfly, but instead of hooking up,
his better judgement kicks in and he tells
her they should stop.
This could be because he actually felt bad
about his actions, but I think it may have
had more to do with that fact that Carla crossed
a line by buzzing his pager while he was at
home.
“Why did you deem it necessary to page me
when you knew I was at home?
You can’t do that.”
Before leaving, a call comes in, which alarms
him because nobody is supposed to know their
location.
On the other end a voice tells him,
“I know what you’re doing...”
The voice is raspy and whispered, but it doesn’t
sound like the voice that Jigsaw usually uses
to address his victims.
“I want to play a game.”
I think this may actually be Zep, who was
also a part of Jigsaw’s game and had to
follow his instructions if he wanted to survive.
Dr. Gordon hurried home after this, not realizing
that he was being followed by a photographer
named Adam Stanheight, who had been hired
by a still suspicious Detective Tapp to keep
an eye on him.
Adam would leave, however, before seeing the
ambush that would take place shortly after
in the parking garage.
Doctor Gordon woke up in a dark, dilapidated
bathroom with his ankle chained to an immovable
pipe.
Across the room, Adam was in a similar predicament,
but Lawrence did not yet know who Adam was.
There is another man in the center of the
room, who is pretending KEY WORD: PRETENDING
to be dead, and this is John Kramer.
Gordon turns on the light and realizes that
everything in the room is old and rusting
other than the clock, which is new.
He finds a tape in his pocket, along with
a bullet and a key.
He throws his tape to Adam for him to play
it out loud.
It’s a voice recording by Jigsaw, telling
Gordon that he’s getting a wake up call.
Roll the tape.
“Every day of your working life you have
given people the news that they’re gonna
die soon.
Now you will be the cause of death.
Your aim in this game is to kill Adam.”
Jigsaw tells him he has to kill Adam by 6
and gives him two clues: the red substance on
the ground is actually laced with poison and
X marks the spot.
He also says that Alison and Diana’s lives
are at stake at well, and a whisper at the
end: follow your heart.
Gordon notices the heart on the toilet, which
leads to Adam finding the hacksaws in there,
but they aren’t strong enough to cut the
chains.
That’s when Dr. Gordon realizes their purpose
is to cut off their feet.
He remembers about Amanda, and how Jigsaw
was still on the loose after that.
They discover a camera is watching them behind
the mirror, and Gordon begins to think more
creatively about how to overcome the game
by likening it to his work.
“To overcome something you have to understand
what a perfect engine it is.
That’s how you fight disease.”
This line shows John Kramer why Lawrence is
actually a perfect candidate to win the game
and become his successor.
Gordon doesn’t have the engineering know-how
that Kramer does, but he shows an ability
to use concepts in what he does know, medicine,
to accomplish whatever he puts his mind to.
But Gordon would have to be pushed to his
limit before having the opportunity to prove
his worth.
While reflecting on the last words he said
to his daughter, he shows Adam a picture of
her from his wallet, and Adam finds a clue
that leads him to ask Gordon to try turning
out the lights.
Glow in the dark paint illuminates the X,
and Gordon smashes through to find a box containing
a phone and two cigarettes.
Gordon is suspicious about how Adam knew to
turn off the lights, and Adam eventually reveals
that he was hiding a note found in the wallet
on the back of a picture of Alison and Diana
being held captive.
Upon seeing this photo, Gordon emotionally
breaks down.
“WHAT DID YOU DO TO THEM YOU BASTARD?”
But hold on… is Gordon really losing his
cool right here?
I think maybe not.
See, Gordon already knew that his family was
in danger, plus he’s never demonstrated
anything other being cool, collected and calculating
when faced with any kind of adversity; whether
it be his unstable wife, being accused of
commiting a crime or finding himself in a
life or death stakes escape room.
Then take his next move into account.
He devises a plan where he pretends to kill
Adam by whispering to him to play dead while
the lights are off and making it look like
he tossed the cigarette dipped in poison rather
than the clean one.
With this plan in mind, it makes sense that
Dr. Gordon would want to sell the performance
by pretending to have a meltdown over this
photo, making it look like there was a valid
reason that he now decided to kill Adam.
This level of thoroughness is another great
example of why Lawrence possesses the material
needed to be Jigsaw.
Unfortunately for Dr. Gordon, Adam’s acting
is not quite as on point as his own.
OK, I have to roll it.
It’s so bad.
It wouldn’t have mattered though, because
Jigsaw has implemented a safe-check by sending
an electric shock through Adam to ensure that he’s
really dead, which obviously, he isn’t.
That’s when the phone that Dr. Gordon found
starts ringing, and it’s his daughter Diana
telling him that the bad man from her room
is holding them hostage with a gun.
The captor also puts Alison on the line, and
she tells him not to believe Adam’s lies.
“He knows you.
He knew all about you before today.”
Let me just make a note of that.
So Gordon finds out the truth about Adam,
that he’s a private photographer hired to
follow Dr. Gordon and gather photos of what
he’s been doing.
After revealing these photos, Adam notices
one that he did not take, and asks Gordon
if somebody else had been at the house.
Lawrence determines that it’s Zep, the orderly,
and upon putting a face to his daughter’s
kidnapper, he really does break down into
a fit of rage.
Time expires on the game and another call
comes in on the cell phone, but this time
it’s Alison.
He hears a struggle on the phone, and bursts into tears when he hears
gunfire and screaming on the other end of
the line.
He sobs on the bathroom floor, where he’s
electrocuted, which may have been Jigsaw giving
him one more wake up call to spring into action.
Dr. Gordon was at rock bottom, and he 👅 had
👅 reached 👅 his 👅 breaking-point.
He goes ballistic when the phone rings again
and he’s unable to reach it.
Roll it.
"Noooo!
F*** this s***!
AHHHH!!!
AHHHHHHSDFLJKFSDJKL"
"Lawrence!"
Although he looks crazy, it’s important
to note, that this is what Jigsaw would consider
to be cured.
Because Gordon was being tested for his inability
to feel passion, this…
"AHHHHHHHHHHH!!!!"
"Lawrence!"
*laughing* could at least be considered passion.
And that’s enough to motivate him to cave
into Jigsaw’s demands and cut off his own
foot with the hacksaw.
It would seem that even in this emotional
state, Gordon did not lose his intelligence
and witty thinking.
He’s somehow able to communicate to Adam
that he wants to try the “play dead” trick
one more time.
I’m guessing while we see the back of his
head right here, he winks, and then deliberately
misses the gunshot.
This ends up working to his advantage when
Zep arrives at the bathroom to execute him
for failing to win the game before time ran out, because
Adam is able to get in a surprise attack and
disarm Zep.
Gordon goes to get help, and promises Adam
he’ll come back to rescue him.
He crawls away using his one foot, and cauterizes
the wound by burning it on a steaming hot
pipe.
But as he continues to hobble away, he loses
too much blood and is on the verge of passing
out when he encounters an unlikely saviour.
Dr. Lawrence Gordon had basically run out
of strength as he tried to navigate his way
out of the dark corridors beyond the dilapidated
bathroom’s confines, and ended up collapsing
on the floor.
After Jigsaw revealed himself to Adam as the
man in the center of the bathroom game, he
made his way out to find Lawrence who had
passed his test.
He drags him to safety and splashes some water
on his face while congratulating him on his
survival.
"Ay congratulations!
It's a celebration!"
In the coming weeks he nursed Dr. Gordon until
his wound had healed, and gave him a prosthetic
foot.
When his health returned to him, he, like
Amanda before him was grateful to Jigsaw for
making him cherish his life once more, and
came on as a disciple and accomplice to Jigsaw’s
work over the next couple years.
At some point, Dr. Gordon left the Angel of
Mercy Hospital to go to work at Saint Eustace
Hospital.
I think this change may have been so he could
assist John with testing some of his old co-workers
at The Angel of Mercy from a safe distance.
Unlike some of his other followers, Jigsaw
saw great potential in Dr. Gordon and kept
him a secret from the other apostles.
Lawrence became Jigsaw’s go-to guy whenever
one of his traps or games required some kind
of surgery or medical expertise.
One example of this was in October of 2005
when he helped Jigsaw set up The Death Mask
Trap by using his surgical skills to sew a
key behind the victim’s right eye, which
he would have to remove in order to escape.
Fans of Saw II noticed early on that the surgeon
seen in the video had a limp, and theorized
it could be Dr. Gordon.
In April of 2006, he assisted in the creation
of the Mausoleum trap by sewing shut one man’s
eyes and another man’s mouth, forcing them
to learn a better way to communicate in order
to avoid being pinched by this powerful mechanism.
Not long after, Jigsaw was nearly on his deathbed
while putting together a game that would test
Amanda Young and a father named Jeff.
"My name Jeff."
Gordon recommends that John also include Jeff’s
wife, Lynn Denlon who had worked under him
when John was diagnosed at Angel of Mercy.
John would have Lynn perform the brain surgery
necessary for her to prove her worth and keep
John alive long enough to see the end of Jeff’s
trial.
After John passed away, Gordon stayed in the
shadows as another Jigsaw disciple, Mark Hoffman,
carried on John’s work.
Lawrence demonstrates that he is still devoted
to John’s teachings, even after John’s
death, by leaving Hoffman a warning when he
starts to stray from Jigsaw’s ideals.
He leaves an anonymous note reading “I know
who you are,” in order to try to give Hoffman
a hint that he doesn’t just have free reign
to corrupt Jigsaw’s legacy.
Gordon would secretly keep close tabs on Hoffman
from there on out.
In July of 2006, he received a parcel through
the mail slot in his door at the hospital.
He opened it to find a video tape with one
final request from John Kramer.
He wanted Dr. Gordon to look after his ex-wife
Jill Tuck.
“Watch over Jill.
And should anything happens to her,
I want you to act immediately
on my behalf.
In return for that, I will keep no more secrets
from you.”
I don’t know what secrets he thought he
was going to learn with Jigsaw being dead,
but he’s happy to honor John’s request
anyways.
At some point, Gordon also starts attending
this support group for Jigsaw survivors.
I think he’s mostly there to keep tabs on
the victims that he helped rehabilitate and make
sure they don’t relapse or anything, because
he tends to sit in a chair outside of the
perimeter of the group and seldom participate
himself.
That is until one meeting in March of 2007,
when a man named Bobby Dagen attends the group
as part of a press tour for his book, S.U.R.V.I.V.E:
My Story of Overcoming Jigsaw.
Dr. Gordon sees just one issue with this publication.
He knows full well that Bobby Dagen was never
one of the Jigsaw victims.
So he kind of calls him out on it, in what
his probably my favorite scene involving Dr. Gordon.
Let's roll it.
[slow clap]
“Remarkable.
If not a little perverse.
I’m sure I speak for everyone here when
I saw how grateful we are to be part of your…
promotional DVD.”
That’s hilarious.
And I low how the camera operator is like,
‘oh, we gotta get this.’
And then everyone else starts clapping.
That’s remarkable.
But that month, Lawrence continues to keep
a watchful eye over Jill Tuck and of course,
her enemy, Mark Hoffman.
On March 12th 2007, Hoffman is finally able
to catch up with and exact his revenge on
Jill, which means Gordon is obligated to act
immediately.
Hoffman packs a bag of supplies and sets fire
to his safehouse before setting out to make
his escape, but he’s met with three people
in pig masks who are led by Dr. Lawrence Gordon.
It would seem that Gordon has taken a page
from his master and acquired a couple of disciples
of his own.
He follows John’s instructions to leave
Hoffman in the location that means the most
to him, the place where he overcame Jigsaw’s
trial: the dilapidated bathroom.
But Hoffman is not given the same option that
he had 2 and a half years ago.
He pulls the last remaining hacksaw out of
Hoffman’s reach and throws it out of the
room, leaving him to die and fulfilling his
teacher’s final request.
"NOOO!"
“Game over.”
"NOOOOO!!!!"
This would leave Gordon as the only living
true successor to Jigsaw, and that’s the
exciting part about this character.
In 2016, a forgotten disciple from John Kramer’s
past, a man named Logan Nelson, re-emerges
and uses the Jigsaw name to get revenge on
a cop that had wronged him and many others.
While this man was trained by Kramer at one
time, he has stayed from his ideals in the
same way that Hoffman did.
At the time of recording, we are yet to see
how Dr. Gordon reacts to this, but I imagine,
based on everything that we know about him, that
he’s still keeping a watchful eye and probably
not too happy about Logan Nelson causing his
old master to be dug up from his grave and
having his legacy altered in a negative way
like this.
So it will be interesting to see if Dr. Gordon
decides to intervene.
John’s intention from the very beginning
with Dr. Gordon was to make him cherish his
life by reintroducing passion.
Originally, that is intended to be passion
for his family, Alison and Diana.
It’s never canonically shown what happens
to his wife and daughter, but in an audio
commentary on Saw 7, it’s stated that they
got divorced after Alison saw how Lawrence
had changed following the bathroom game.
There’s nothing in the films to contradict
that, and it does make sense, because they
aren’t present at the support group, but
we can’t say for sure until there some evidence
in a future film.
But what we can say is that passion was reintroduced
into Lawrence’s life anyways, because he
became passionate about Jigsaw’s teachings
and helping people improve their lives using
his methods.
This causes him to become the only one of
Jigsaw’s apprentices to become a true heir
to John’s vision of what Jigsaw could be
and it will be fun to see how this new Jigsaw
continues the spirit of John’s teachings
going forward.
Let me know in the comments though, who else
would you like to see covered here on Horror
History?
I’ve already got a playlist there on the
left of the histories of other Saw characters,
so be sure to check those out and remember
to subscribe to CZsWorld for new horrors every
week, ring that deathbell for notifications
and I’ll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.